so according to the biden administration
the war in afghanistan is over but what
legally allowed that war to happen in
the first place and could it happen
again only congress has the power to
declare war it's right there in article
1 of the constitution so how is it that
presidents basically seem to have
unilateral ability to declare war
whenever they want in this particular
case we're talking about the
authorization for use of military force
or aumf the 2001 aomf allowed the
president to go to war in afghanistan
and there were also aomfs in 1991 and
2002 that allowed the president to go to
war in iraq those are still on the books
which leads many to say that perhaps now
we should remove them since those wars
are over and we don't want presidents
extending those aumfs to go to war in
other places this is part of a
long-standing battle between congress
and the president over who can declare
and continue to go to war it's
absolutely not a settled constitutional
question but the ending of the war in
afghanistan has raised these questions
once again so perhaps this time maybe
something will be done about it